did you learn about the habits of the
rich in terms of like wealth as I think
you and I would probably understand it I
didn't know anything about that I
started studying wealth after I became
wealthy and what do wealthy people do
that you think poor people don't they
pick higher leverage opportunities Poor
Dad says get a job Poor Dad says get a
higher paying job like Rich Dad says
like you know you buy some real estate
and you know it'll appreciate over time
of course you invest in some stocks like
yeah of course poor dads just don't say
that and so you have to like learn that
so I'm grateful in that I didn't have to
learn that because I heard of course you
don't spend your whole income of course
you don't and so there's a lot of of
course you don't that I think I I
inherited just by being like a saving
father but there's also some upper
middle class people who don't save
anything